[Musique]
juste avant Noël, un bon gars en
rouge arrive au cinéma avec son nouvel
acolyte
Fred pourquoi suis-je là tu es dans une version pg-13
de Deadpool filtrée à travers la
prison de l'innocence enfantine et aucun homme
n'a l'innocence enfantine comme toi  Je n'ai eu
personne J'ai besoin de toi presque autant que tu as
besoin de moi Je n'ai pas du tout besoin de toi Moi pour
te détacher une fois que nous aurons fini
un donc Paul pas de
personnage de Deadpool pour les films Marvel nous
sommes Merkel ouais mais tu sais que la
licence Marvel mon Fox c'est comme si les Beatles
étaient produits par Nickelback c'est de la musique
mais ça craint tu étais plus gentil en tant qu'enfant
classé pg-13 engagement limité dans
salles le 12 décembre
vous